foreign
YouTube channel in today's video we will
be talking about Google analytics 4. I'm
going to share with you what is the
difference with universal analytics why
you should go on to Google analytics for
as soon as possible how do you migrate
from Universal analytics to Google
analytics 4 and what are the key
features of Google analytics for also
known as ga4 so I am Mark campman I am
your digital navigator for this video
and as usual like the video and if you
want to subscribe to our Channel click
the Subscribe button below but before we
start let me share with you something
new we have a new course a professional
certificate program in digital marketing
which is a number one digital marketing
course together with marketing lens and
search engine Journal which we have put
together with Purdue University T where
you can learn the top digital marketing
tools with online marketing course
featuring master classes from meta and
Purdue and Harvard publishing case
studies so this course will set you up
for the meta blueprint certification as
well which is Facebook's leading digital
marketing and Facebook marketing course
where you learn how to use Facebook
advertising and managing your Facebook
page so click on this link if you want
to know more about this program but I
would really recommend you have a look
at this and sign up for this course
which is very good value for money but
before we go on let's move on to talk
about Google analytics 4. so Google
analytics was originally launched in
November 2005 as a free web service it
was based on technology from urgent
software corporation which Google had
acquired in April 2005. now the initial
version of Google analytics was a simple
tool for tracking website traffic
tracking page views and basic user
Behavior
in 2007 Google released a major update
to Google analytics known as Google
analytics 2 which introduced new
features like custom reporting and
advanced segmentation
in 2009 Google acquired odometry a
company that specialized in online
attribution and advertising analytics
and it integrated its technology into
Google analytics in 2011 Google released
Google analytics premium in 2012 Google
did a very important announcement which
was the Google Universal analytics which
was a major overhaul of the Google
analytics as we knew then and it
introduced new tracking methods and
cross-device measurement capabilities
Google also in that year introduced a
Google analytics 360 Suite a suite of
Enterprise analytics tools that included
Google analytics premium as well as
other products for data management and
optimization
in 2019 with the growth in Mobile yeah
Google launched Google analytics app and
web a new version of analytics that
combined web and app tracking into one
platform and then in 2020 Google
launched Google analytics for the
successor to Universal analytics which
introduced new features such as
Predictive Analytics AI powered insights
and improved privacy control and to be
precise the launch date was October 14
2020.
so here is what we're going to be
talking about but before I go into that
let me give you a warning Google
analytics 4 is Google's next Generation
measurement solution and it is replacing
Universal Analytics
and it's very important to understand
that on July the 1st
2023 yeah Google will stop processing
data from Universal analytics properties
which basically means it will no longer
track data from websites that run on
universal analytics Google strongly
encourages you to make the switch to
Google analytics 4 as soon as possible
why because you will then start building
up a history of data and you don't start
completely from scratch yeah in 20 in
July 2023 so what's going to happen
beginning in March 2023 if you haven't
already migrated to Google analytics 4
Google will create one for you unless
you opt out this new property will be
based on the settings in your Universal
analytics property
yeah if you have already created a ga4
property and the property is connected
to a universal analytics property then
Google will copy over any configurations
like goals and audiences from your UA
property that you have not marked as
complete in your ga4 property unless
again you opt out
until July the 1st 2023 you can continue
to use and collect data and new data in
your Universal analytics property but
after July 2023 you'll be able to access
your previous process data in your
Universal analytics for at least another
six months
yes so bear in mind that it's only
um tracking it for another six months so
it's very important that if your
historic data is important for you that
you export your historic data during
that time otherwise it'll be gone yeah
so Google will provide a future date
when existing Universal analytics
properties will no longer be available
yeah so after that future date you'll no
longer be able to see your Universal
analytics reports in the analytics
interface or access your Universal
analytics data via an API
okay so it is very important that you
start setting up your Google analytics
as soon as possible and that's what
we're going to be talking about in this
video so here is the agenda we're going
to be talking about what is Google
Analytics
we'll talk about what is Google
analytics for we show you some of the
differences between Google analytics 4
and Universal analytics we'll look at
the June of Google analytics for data
model will give you a demo of Google
analytics 4 I'm going to give you the
top 10 tips and tricks and we're going
to close with a case study and for
convenience sake I'm now going to be
talking about ga4 for Google analytics 4
and UA for Google Universal Analytics
okay so before we go into Google
analytics let's talk about web analytics
for a second what is web analytics now
with web analytics refers to the process
of collecting measuring analyzing and
Reporting data related to your website
and the behavior of the people that
visit your website this data can be used
to gain insights into how your visitors
are interacting with your website which
pages are most popular how long visitors
are staying on your website or on a page
which channels are driving the most
traffic and a lot more data that you can
get from this
they typically provide a wide range of
metrics like page views unique visitors
bound rates conversion rates average
time on the page yeah and by analyzing
these metrics you can make Market driven
decisions yeah and data-driven decisions
about how to optimize your website for
better performance better user
engagement better user experience and
increased conversions and increase
revenues
it can also be used to track the
effectiveness of your advertising
campaigns of your marketing campaigns of
your website design the functionality
yeah and the impact of changes that you
make on your website over time so
overall website analytics is an
essential tool for a business or an
organization that has a website because
it provides valuable insights on how
visitors are interacting with your
website and it helps you drive the
improvements that you have to make to be
more successful with your website so
it's very important that you understand
that yes so now then what is Google
Analytics
yeah so
um now Google analytics is a free web
analytics servers that's offered by
Google and that helps you to track and
analyze website traffic and user
Behavior
now it's important to know that to use
Google analytics you must install a
tracking code on your website on every
page of your website which allows Google
to collect data on that particular page
yeah on usage and on usual Behavior
this data is then aggregated and
presented in a user-friendly dashboard
in Google and lytics where users can
access a wide range of reports and
analytics tools to gain insights into
the website performance and user
Behavior
so Google analytics is a powerful web
Analytics tool that provides a wealth of
insights into how users find and use
your website it gives a fantastic deep
understanding of the visitors of your
website including their demographics
their behavior their interests and other
metrics that you're getting
it provides a wide range of data and
insights like number of visitors to the
website where visitors are coming from
which pages are most popular how long
are visitors staying on a page which
channels are driving the most traffic
it also provides insights on visitor
demographics like age like gender like
location and interest which is
information that can be used to to
Target your audience and tailor content
to um and optimize your marketing
efforts
so the current version of Google
analytics is called Universal analytics
or Google UA
this data model is designed to help
website owners and marketeers understand
how users interact with your website
the data model is built around a
hierarchical structure that allows
website owners to collect and analyze
data from various user interactions on
the website at the top of the hierarchy
are the accounts
yeah they represent a collection of
websites or mobile apps owned by you by
a single entity by a user when each each
within each account there can be
multiple properties
they represent individual websites or
mobile apps
yes so each property has a unique
tracking ID that is used to collect data
on user interactions
within each property there can be
multiple views which represents
different perspectives on the data
collected for that property
yeah they can be used to segment data
based on specific criteria such as
geography device type or user Behavior
at the lowest level of the hierarchy are
the data collection objects which
represents the individual interactions
that user have with a website or a
mobile app
yeah so these objects they include page
views they include events transactions
and other user interactions that are
tracked using Google Analytics
overall the universal analytics data
model provides a very flexible and
scalable framework for collecting and
analyzing data from user interactions on
websites and mobile devices
so Google analytics provides a wealth of
information about how visitors interact
with your website which is crucial for
marketing people to optimize their
website
yeah so the information can be used to
identify areas where the website is
performing well and where it isn't
performing well where it needs
Improvement for example if a website has
a very high bounce rate on certain pages
this may include that the content on
those pages is not engaging enough or
that there are technical issues
preventing users from accessing the
content
by identifying these issues you can make
data driven decisions to optimize the
website and improve the engagement so by
using Google analytics you can gain
insights into key metrics such as
traffic sources bounce rates time spents
on the site and conversion rates
it helps you to make informed decision
that lead to increased traffic
engagement increase conversion and
ultimately Drive business growth
now then what is Google analytics 4 or
ga4
ga4 represents a major update to the
Google analytics platform and addresses
many of the limitations of UA
while UA provided very valuable insights
into website performance and user
Behavior there were various limitations
to it that led Google to use ga4 one of
the main limitations of UA
was that it relied heavily on cookies to
track user Behavior
and with the right of privacy concerns
and the increasing use of ad blockers
cookies became less reliable as a
tracking mechanism leading to gaps in
data collection
also UA was not designed to track user
Behavior across multiple devices making
it difficult to gain a holistic view of
user interactions
GA has been designed to address these
limitations by providing a more flexible
and privacy friendly tracking mechanism
it uses a new tracking code that relies
of a combination of cookies and
server-side tracking to collect data on
user Behavior
and this approach provides you more
accurate and reliable data collection
while also addressing privacy concerns
so let's dig a bit deeper in Google
Analytics 4.
so ga4 is the new version of Google's
web analytics platform and it decides to
provide you more advanced features and
capabilities
as I mentioned at the beginning of
today's session it is set to replace UA
by July 2023
now there are three groundbreaking
features in ga4 that you need to be
aware of
first of all ga4 is an event driven data
model it uses an event-driven data model
which means that it tracks user
interactions as discrete events rather
than page views as we saw in using in
Universal Analytics
this gives you more flexibility it gives
you more detail in trekking usual
Behavior as you can stretch specific
actions that users can take on your site
or your app it also allows for more
cross device and more accurate
cross-device and cross-platform
measurements as events can be tracked
across different devices and different
channels
the second major Improvement is the AI
powered insights ga4 includes Advanced
artificial intelligence and machine
learning capabilities such as Predictive
Analytics and user life cycle analytics
it helps you better understand your
users and therefore make better
data-driven decisions for example it can
provide insights on which users are more
likely to convert or churn and offer
recommendations on how to optimize your
website or app for better performance
the third major Improvement is the
improved privacy controls ga4 includes
new privacy controls and data retention
settings which give users more control
over their data and allow website owners
to comply with regulations such as the
gdpr and CCPA
for example you can choose to
automatically delete user data after a
certain period of time or provide
opt-out options for users who do not
want their data to be tracked which of
course helps to build trust with users
and this demonstrates a commitment to
responsible data use
so let's expand on this event-based Data
Tracking a key feature of ga4
in UA website owners and marketeers
could track user Behavior by tracking
page views which provided a high level
view of how users were engaging with a
website
however this approach had limitations in
terms of tracking more specific user
interactions such as clicks on a
particular button or filling out a form
ga4's event-driven data model allows you
to track a wide range of user
interactions and discrete events it
provides more flexibility in tracking
user behavior and allows for more
granular insights into how users are
engaging with your website for example
website owners and marketeers can track
user interactions such as clicks form
submissions video plays and downloads
among many other interactions
by tracking user interactions as events
ga4 allows you to Define custom events
and parameters there are a number of
default events that come with ga4 but
you can specify your own events as well
so you can track specific user behaviors
that are unique to your website and your
business goals
for example an e-commerce site could
Define custom events to track user
interactions with their shopping cart or
checkout process providing valuable
insights into how users are progressing
through the conversion funnel
through this events-based trekking ga4
provides more accurate and more
comprehensive views of user behavior and
allow you for better cross-device and
cross-platform measurement
ga4 also provides new privacy control
and retention settings which give users
more control over their data
it allows website owners to comply with
regulations such as to gdpr and the CCPA
for example you can choose to
automatically delete user data over a
certain period of time or provide opt
out of options for users who do not want
their data to be tracked
one of the key privacy features of ga4
is the ability for website owners to
Define their own data retention policies
this allows you to specify how long you
want to retain user Data before it's
automatically deleted
yep and that helps you with complying to
gdpr regulations which require data to
be kept for a limited period of time
and another key privacy feature is ga4's
ability to use server-side tagging this
approach to tracking user behavior in
false sending data directly from the
server to Google analytics rather than
relying on client-side tracking via
cookies
yes so it reduces your Reliance on
cookies which is a really important part
of the Privacy regulations
so Google analytics 4 also integrates
seamlessly with Google's other marketing
and advertising platforms such as Google
ads and Google's marketing platform
by integrating with Google ads ga4
allows you to track the performance of
your ads directly within the ga4
interface it makes it easier to measure
the effectiveness of your ad campaigns
and to optimize your campaigns for
better performance yeah so you can for
example use ga4 to track the key metrics
such as ADD clicks conversions and
revenues generated from your ads
by integrated with Google's marketing
platform ga4 allows you to gain a more
comprehensive view of your marketing
performance across multiple channels
this integration allows you to track
user Behavior across a range of
marketing channels including search
display social media and video
it allows for more seamless data sharing
between the platforms yes so website
owners can use the data collected in ga4
to inform their Google ads campaign or
use data from the Google ads to inform
their ga4 reporting
right so having that done as an
introduction of ga4 let's look at some
of the differences between Google
analytics the universal the Google UA
and the ga4
so let's summarize these difference the
first one of course that we talked about
was the event-based tracking yeah so the
main focus of universal analytics is on
tracking page views and sessions which
may not provide enough detailed
information and can limit the depths of
insights that websites owners can obtain
with ga4 there is greater emphasis on
event-based tracking which enables you
to Monitor and track specific user
actions and events on your website or
app such as clicks form submissions or
video plays
the next one was the data model
yeah so the hierarchy data model used by
Universal analytics is based on
dimensions and metrics
and this can be less flexible and it's
more rigid in nature where ga4 uses
events and parameters to closely Monitor
and analyze user Behavior across various
touch points and devices
the soga4 allows for more precise and
flexible Data Tracking giving you the
ability to collect and analyze data from
a wider range of touch points and more
devices
the next big difference was in the cross
device tracking
so the cross device tracking
capabilities on UA are limited which
primarily relies on cookies for this
purpose where in ga4 its Advanced
tracking capabilities ga4 greatly
enhances cross-device tracking enabling
you to gain valuable insights into user
Behavior across various devices and
platforms
and then there were the Privacy features
one of the key differentiators of ga4
universal analytics does not offer some
data privacy features however they are
and those that they that they do offer
they are not as advanced as the privacy
and data retention settings available in
ga4
yeah ga4 provides automatic data Erasure
and built-in data controls which helps
you to comply with data privacy laws and
also gives users more control over their
data
and the next one was the integration
with Google ads and other Google
products yeah but particularly the
Google ads integration is important so
the universal analytics has a very
limited integration with Google's other
marketing products like Google ads while
there is some integration yes such as
the ability to link Google ads and
analytics accounts the level of
integration is not as seamless as you
will get in ga4
ga4 Works a much deeper as a much deeper
integration with Google ads the
data-driven model allows for more
granular tracking of AD performance yeah
enabling you to understand the best
um the the the results that you're
getting from your campaigns
so those are the key differences between
ga4 and UA and then let's have a look at
the ga4 data model in a bit more detail
because the data model ish
is fundamentally different than on UA
where in UA you had the um the
hierarchical model GA force model is
based on the event tracking
yes so the ga Force data model focuses
on tracking user interactions with a
website or an app as events
and therefore you get more granular and
flexible tracking of user Behavior
you can customize your tracking by
defining custom events parameters and
user properties enabling you to spec to
track specific actions and behaviors
yeah so the ga4 data model is designed
to provide insights into individual user
Behavior across multiple touch points
and devices
allowing you to give a better
understanding of your audience
so in the ga4 data model events are
specific actions that users take while
interacting with your website
these actions can be tracked as discrete
events providing owners website owners
with more granular and actionable data
events can be like clicks on a button a
form submission video plays and other
types of user interactions by tracking
events you gain a better understanding
of user Behavior user preferences and it
makes you in a much better position to
make decisions on improving website
performance and user experience
the parameters they provide additional
context and information about the event
such as the value of a transaction the
category of a product Feud or the name
of a button clicked by leveraging
parameters you can get an even better
Insight you can get better segments in
your audience and you get more detailed
insights into user behaviors
so together events and parameters
provide you with granular understanding
of the user behavior of people visiting
your website
okay so enough about the theory let's go
and have a look at Google analytics 4 in
more detail by giving you a demo of the
most important functionality of it
so the best way to access Google
analytics 4 is through the marketing
platform.google.com about
and if you scroll down here you can see
that there is Advanced solutions for
large Enterprises and here you see
analytics for Integrated Solutions for
every Market here
so learn more about analytics that's
where we're going and here you accept
all the details that you need for your
Google Analytics
so there's two ways that you can go and
get your Google analytics setup you can
if you have already got a website on
universal Analytics
then what you do you sign in to
Analytics
that takes you to your existing
Universal analytics account and then you
will see how to upgrade to Google
analytics 4 or you can just start from
scratch with get started today but let's
go the route of signing to analytics so
if we sign into Analytics
it takes you to your existing website
and in my case this is my own website
yeah here you see it's already on ga4
because I've already created a ga4
account so I'm going to change this and
I'm going to take this to my UA account
okay so this is my Universal analytics
account
here when I go there you see immediately
because it is a UA account at the top an
important message that Google says on
the 1st of July 23 we will stop
processing data
Etc yeah and then here you can go to
manage the ga4 migration that's where I
click and now it takes me to my either
the process of turning my UA into a ga4
but since I've already done that it just
says go to your ga4 property
hmm
and by going to my ga4 property I now go
into the setup assistant and the setup
assistant will talk you through all the
steps like data collection the property
settings integration with Google ads
linked to Google ads Etc and there's an
advanced setup as well but these are the
basic steps that we need to go through
and the first very important part that I
need to do is to need to collect
websites and app data so I haven't
started that yet yeah so I am going to
manage the data streams
so here you see my ga4 property but I
need an I can add another app stream if
I want to or another website but I only
have my website so here I just click on
the details
and this is where I have my stream name
my stream URL My Stream ID my
measurement ID yep and here I see the
enhanced measurements which are the
events that I'm tracking yeah I can
modify event I can create custom events
and here I see my Google tag
instructions
so here I can view the tag instructions
yeah and here I can go
let me have a look
so here you see install your Google tag
and here I can get the installation
instructions I can install it with my
CMS
if that's on the list where I can just
copy the tag ID
so when I have WordPress for instance
there is a ga4 plugin and the only thing
I need to do is to add plugin code yep
and that is this the tag ID or I can
install manually and that is the piece
of code that I need to install on my
website using Google tag manager now I'm
not going to demo that I'm just making
you aware of this yeah in the next
module next video we're going to be
talking about Google tag manager so
that's watch that video if you want to
know how to take this piece of code and
add it to your website
okay so that gives me all the data I
need to connect my my website to Google
analytics so it starts tracking the data
all right so that is how I can set up
the website for ga4 if I don't want that
I want to start from scratch yeah if I
go back to this site I said get started
today it will again take you to your
existing property
but it will then actually
show you here at the bottom continue
setting up your property try the
analytics demo account yeah or learn
more about data analytics
um yeah and get started with the Google
analytics four so lots of things that
you can get here and it makes it very
easy for you to migrate to your to
Google analytics for okay now
let's look into Google analytics for
itself I don't want to do that on my
website I actually want to go to the
Google analytics demo account Google has
a merchandise store and in this
merchandise store they have made the
analytics data available for people to
learn about Google analytics so that's
why we're going to have a look at we're
going to use the Google merchandise
store data to look at Google analytics
for
okay so when you go to Google analytics
for the home page as it were you see
this screen
yeah here you see your menu where you
have your home
yeah that is kind of your dashboards
it's top level reports personalized it
shows reports that you recently viewed
automated insights Etc
you don't have your reports
in the reports they show you
pre-configured reports dedicated reports
how people find your website the pages
they viewed if they convert it to
demographics details about the devices
they use and so on there is the explore
in Explorer you can create your own
reports and visualize data in different
ways like simple tables funnel
visualizations
Etc
then you have your integration with
advertising it lets you if you dedicated
attribution reports see the
relationships between different channels
and how they lead to conversions on your
website and then there is the admin and
in the admin you can access additional
settings for accounts and for your your
property and this is also where you can
create your events your parameters and
your conversions
yeah so there are many reports in Google
analytics 4 which you don't have to use
them all yeah so
um but let's give you some of the
highlights yes so the home is your
dashboard so it gives you the last seven
days by default you can change that of
course you can change it last 28 last 19
you can do comparisons as well yes so
you can also see a trend line
for the selected item yeah so and then
here you see the last sort of the last
the users in the last 30 minutes
your report you've recently viewed and
here it shows you some suggested reports
and here you have to Google AI the
insights and the recommendations yes so
this is very useful information you can
get from Google in
um additional knowledge about what's
happening in your Google analytics so
then let's look at the reports there are
multiple reports the most important one
to start with is your report snapshots
your report snapshot is similar to your
home report it gives you users new users
total revenue yeah users in the last 30
minutes it gives you insights yeah so
basic reporting that you get here it's
your top campaigns users by country how
active users are active users trending
how well do you retain your users
Etc so lots of data that you can get on
this page
okay so that is your report snapshot it
then goes into real time real time we
saw that in Google Universal analytics
as well here you see it actually in a
much more extended version yep so it
shows the people that are currently
viewing your website so it's very useful
to check where people are lending on
your website for instance when you run
an email campaign check if people do get
to the associated pages with your email
campaign each card include a bar chart
yeah and of course read the users per
minutes from right to left yes so
because this is now yeah and this is
sort of 30 minutes ago
okay so we can see the content people
are viewing you can see the pages they
are viewing the events that are being
collected you can also see the
conversions and the user properties that
people have been collecting you can also
see the granular details of people so
which is the view the user snapshots
yeah that is a nice little gimmick but
it can also be very useful
it gives a breakdown of the actual
session in events
yeah so here you see uh on a Huawei
phone in Riyadh yeah so you see the
exact sort of event what is happening
they're scrolling they're viewing a
promotion yeah so and if you click on
there's the user engagement if I click
on that then that gives me all the
parameters and the user properties that
you want from that that session so very
useful to get
nitty-gritty data about user engagement
if you want another user just click on
this Arrow yep and if you want to close
this here is the exit snapshots so those
are the real-time overviews and then
here you have on the kind of the life
cycle yeah the reports from acquisition
to engagement to monetization and
retention four categories of reports
kind of following the buyer life cycle
first of all is the acquisition reports
so if we go to the overview it gives you
information about how people are finding
your website it gives you information
about the users it gives you information
about the traffic
so here you see the number of users the
users in the last 30 minutes here you
see users by default Channel grouping
like user analytics I can add an
additional Dimension as well for
instance first user source and medium so
you can say how they were communicated
to and where they were communicated yes
so really useful breakdown of the
information and here you see the
lifetime value that you get from a user
yeah so that's very useful information
so you can also change the date of
course of the report and you can again
compare with previous periods as well
which is stem similar like what we saw
in user Universal analytics as well the
user analytics shows you metrics how
users fund your website at their first
visit
yes so the different channels that they
used hereby
um by bars and by line yeah here you see
the different
um the different channels that they they
use you see a number of new users engage
session engagement rate engage sessions
per user the average engagement time
it's a very useful data that you can see
here and of course you can add a second
dimension as well for instance if you
want to see the way people found your
website combined with the landing page I
can pay put here for instance with the
page and Landing Page Plus query string
so then it gives you where they landed
on your website as well
so very useful the next one is the
traffic acquisition
the traffic acquisition shows you how
people found your website to start each
of their sessions it goes beyond the
very first time they found your website
it's based on sessions so we can see
session based metrics in the table again
you can change the dimension here and
add a second dimension using the plus
sign
we then go to the second category which
are the engagement reports yeah they
show you what people are doing on your
website the pages people are viewing and
the events that are automatically
collected using the enhanced measurement
feature and any other event you are
tracking yes so if we select pages and
screens it shows you the pages people
are viewing on your website
yeah based Pages reported based on page
title ordered by a number of views
number of page huge number of users
change the default setting as well yeah
so I can add here more information so
page title and screen name I can add if
I want to so different things that I can
I can add yeah so here's the page title
and Screen class and I can add a
dimension for instance I can say page
cream landing page and query screen
so I can get more detail here yes or you
can also get to the top level summary in
the overview report so events shows you
all of the events that have been
collected
yeah and you can get click on the name
of the event to get more details on the
event
and the conversion report
yeah yeah so you see the the details of
the event
okay the conversions
is the total number of conversions for
the date range based on the events that
have been marked as a conversion
okay we then have the monetization
so in the monetization reports you have
e-commerce reports and reports for
in-app purchase and publisher ads these
two reports are to measure purchases and
add Revenue in mobile apps
yes so the total revenue from all the
events and the e-commerce revenue is
from transactions
yeah then you see the total number of
people who made a purchase and the total
who made the first time purchase
both are user-based metrics next to that
we see the average purchase Revenue per
year and the top items being sold
remaining cards are blank yeah because
Google decided not to implement
e-commerce tracking for item lists and
item promotions and coupons
okay so that is your
monetization you have e-commerce
purchases and you also have your in-app
purchases but we haven't got any uh app
integration here so there's nothing
there and then we have your retention
this group shows users in cohorts based
on when users view your websites shows
new and returning but this is all based
on Go words that you've that you've set
and then there is your demographics
report as well
yes so if I go to the user reports there
are your demographic and your Tech
reports demographic is where people are
coming from their location their age
their gender and what have you pretty
standards there's demographic details as
well and then you have your users by
country or by City
yeah and you have your Tech reports
yeah and the tech report shows you the
devices that they use and everything
else in relation to devices and
operating systems
okay so those are the standard reports
in
um Google analytics four yeah so let's
go to the next section and that is the
explore section
in the explore section you can create
additional reports
yep there is a library of reports
already available in here that you can
get yeah but you can create your own
reports as well there are blank reports
by clicking on plus there are free form
reports they can create any type of
chart that you would like there's funnel
exploration reports they let you
visualize particular steps you want
people to travel through like steps to
complete a lead form or steps to
complete a an e-commerce checkout you
can do path exploration reports they let
you visualize the path that people take
through your pages or other actions they
take on your website there is your
segment overlap lets you apply multiple
segments to see if users are included in
one or more of your segments there's
cohort exploration that lets you group
users based on the days weeks or visit
your website and then there is the user
lifetime reports they let you view
additional lifetime user metrics
yes so in your own property you will
also find user Explorer which lets you
drill down on the individual users that
isn't available in the Google demo
property yeah so click on any of these
options we'll pre-load a
um we'll load a pre-configured template
and then here of course you see the
reports that are used by other people so
if you want to create a report from
scratch you just go to the beginning and
you click on the plus
yep and that is basically it is the
Google data studio interface is very
familiar that you you get here yeah so
you can specify your segments your
dimensions and your metrics and by doing
that that is how you can create your
your report now I'm not going to show
you how to create a report yeah but at
least now you have the the route where
to go to create your own reports
okay then we have the advertising
options yeah that is the last section
here in your reports it shows the
relationship between your different
marketing channels
yeah so and they let you apply
attribution models so the snapshot
shows the top level summary of your
marketing channels you can see which
channels drove the most conversions and
it gives you automated insights based on
the Google machine learning
we can also see that be the most
important touch points that people take
leading to conversions there is the
model comparison report it shows you the
marketing channels on the left and on
the right we see the revenue and the
conversions per Channel
yeah so first is based on the
last click attribution model and the
second one is based on the the data
driven the cross-channel data-driven
attribution model so two different
models you can change those if you want
to yes so but this is where you want to
look for significant changes in the
report changes that have a positive
percentage means that we may be
undervaluing the marketing channel when
we use the last click model
changes they have a negative percent
means that they may be overvaluing the
marketing channel when we use the last
click Channel
yes so that is the um the model
comparison and then there is your
conversion path report that provides a
visual representation of the marketing
touch points people engage with before
converting here we can see how some
wrote shows that some users are engaged
with our organic search listing multiple
times before converting
yeah people can go through multiple
touch points yeah this helps you to
understand the relationship between your
channels and how they drive conversions
on your websites
yeah you can customize the reports by
changing the dimension used for the pass
and you can change the attribution model
as well
okay so that is everything there is on
the reports as it were in the admin you
can configure your Google analytics for
and you see that here on the right you
can configure your data streams you can
configure your events your conversions
and your audiences
yeah so here you see the events that
have been created for the Google
merchandise store
and here you can add additional events
here you can say whether you want to
mark them as a conversion or not of
course I can't edit this because I
haven't got edit right if I go to the
conversions then here you see the
conversion settings
yeah that you can
and the conversions that you have set
you can specify your audiences
audiences is very important
yeah so you can create all the interest
to report on particular groups of users
this is your segmentation as we knew it
in Google Universal analytics yes so you
can for instance users who have made
purchases on the website or users who
haven't converted yet
or you can use it audiences to focus on
reporting you can also use them for
remarketing in your linked Google ads
account
okay so here are your audiences then
here you have your debug View
yeah so that is where you can test your
uh your events here you can have your
product links yeah so you have your
Google ads links ad manager links and
big query link
yes so bigquery is important
yeah where you can actually link to
Google bigquery where you can import
your data to get more
um reports more visualizations on your
data as well as the links with the
display and the video 360 links so lots
of Integrations
um in Google analytics four and that
concludes the Google analytics 4 demo
yeah so in next week's video you will
see we're going to talk about the Google
tag manager and that is where I will
show you how to add the code the the the
tagging code to every page of your
website using the the Google tech
manager but for now this is all I want
to share with you on the Google
analytics demo
so I hope that gave you a better
understanding of how to use Google
analytics for and now let's close
today's session with giving you some
tips and tricks and share with you a
case study of a company that very
successfully used ga4 to achieve their
business objectives so let's start with
my tips and tricks number one use
conversion tracking conversion tracking
is vital in your digital marketing yep
and we're in Universal analytics you
could set up goals in um to to track
conversions in Google analytics for you
can track to set them up as events and
they enable you to measure the
effectiveness of your marketing
campaigns and optimize your websites
accordingly so very important to set up
the conversion tracking
Google analytics comes with a number of
standard events and parameters but I
urge you to use custom events impairment
parameters as well set up your own track
your own events yeah that will give you
additional insights in how your users
are acting on your specific website so
very important to um to do that tip
number three set up audience targeting
yeah ga4 allows you to set up
specialized audiences depending on user
Behavior yeah so thereby you can tailor
your message messaging and offering to
certain audience categories yeah so
they're very Advanced audience targeting
capabilities in ga4 so use those
tip number four use machine learning
insights don't overlook those in
Universal analytics they were kind of
Hidden Away in ga4 they are very clear
start using those yes they give you
insights into user behaviors and Trends
and you can really use that intelligence
to optimize your website and your
marketing campaigns
then set up custom reports the reporting
functionality in ga4 is really good very
extensive yeah lots of standard reports
already in there but create your own
reports thereby you gain a more granular
understanding of user behavior and of
course thereby you can optimize your
website accordingly
so use the data layer yeah that's an
important element of Google analytics
for it allows you to use a data layer to
track custom events and parameters and
gain more detailed insights into user
Behavior
setup data streams
don't limit your data to just your
website yeah so set up a stream for your
website for mobiles for apps yes so you
can then track data from different
streams giving you a more granular
overview of how people are in engaging
and interacting with your various
platforms
use data import yes so ga4 allows you to
import data from other sources like
Google ads to better understand user
behavior and preferences
tip number nine is to use the big query
integration
ga4 integrates with Google's bigquery
data warehouse allowing you to export
your data for further and deeper
analysis and visualization
and then finally monitor your data
privacy yes so website owners can
monitor your data data provide privacy
settings to make sure that they are
compliant with privacy regulations like
gdpr and CCPA
good finally let's close today's video
but looking at a case study of how
McDonald's in Hong Kong use ga4 to grow
their business
show McDonald's Hong Kong were facing
challenges with its online ordering
system which resulted in low conversion
rates and the high bound rates they
adopted ga4 to get a better insight into
user behavior and preferences
and by using ga4's tracking capabilities
they were able to identify the specific
points where customers were dropping off
the ordering process with this
information they made several
improvements to the order flow including
simplifying the menu and making it
easier to customize orders
also they used a ga4s machine learning
capabilities to identify user patterns
and preferences and personalize the
ordering experience for each user
so they use ga4 to improve their mobile
apps performance and increase in-app
orders
by using the event-based tracking and
data analysis they were able to gain
insights into user behavior and make
data-driven decision to improve the user
behavior and as a result they saw a
significant increase in in-app orders as
well as improvements in user engagement
and retention
as I said they use predictive audiences
in ga4 to identify users who were more
likely to purchase within the app they
use machine learning models to analyze
user behaviors such as in-app purchases
time spent on the app and menu item
preferences to create these predictive
audiences and once these audiences were
created they used them to Target their
advertising efforts to these high value
users with personalized offers and
promotions
so as a result of all these changes
McDonald's Hong Kong saw a 550 increase
in app orders yeah as well as an
increase in customer satisfaction and
customer loyalty
the success of this case study
demonstrates the power of ga4 in
providing insights and actionable data
for improving customer experiences and
driving business growth
yeah so the link to this article of this
case study you will find in the um in
the
the the the notes by in the video yeah
and I highly recommend you read this
article to get more insights in how
McDonald's in Hong Kong use ga4 to grow
their their business so that concludes
today's session as we say it's a wrap a
short introduction to Google analytics
four if you want to know more check out
the simply learn courses and if you like
the video click the like button or the
share button and of course if you want
to subscribe to our Channel click on the
Subscribe button below so thereby you
can join our Learners community on
YouTube thank you very much and I'll see
you at the next video
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here